well I think we must be very careful not
to talk ourselves into doom and gloom
the survey that you conducted is
slightly at odds with other surveys I've
seen which are more optimistic of course
it's possible that there's going to be a
slowdown in the world economy and in the
UK economy even if the UK economy does
slow down a bit
probably going to grow as fast as that
of Germany in probably faster than that
of most countries in the euro zone we
may see where we will see I think
inflation going up because of the
depreciation of serling but that's a
once-and-for-all
effect you bring go on unless Stirling
weakens a lot further notwithstanding
the state of consumer confidence it's
very very clear that a lot of business
people are extremely unhappy about the
lack of clarity they're getting from the
government's on the shape of brexit
negotiations right now isn't it well I
can understand that and up to a point
sympathize with it because business
people like everything to remain the
same they don't like change they don't
like uncertainty but at the same time I
think they've got to be realistic and
they're being unrealistic you can't
expect the government to say this is our
ultimate aim this is the very best we're
aiming for they want to show their
negotiating hand they didn't want to
show what ultimately they might settle
for I mean I personally think it's
perfectly obvious what the government
aiming at even though they weren't
explicitly say so it is to have a free
trade agreement with the European Union
that's probably what it is and to leave
things in day to day life very much as
they are now that may not be a hundred
percent attainable but you can't expect
the government to put its head on the
block and say this is what we want but
when Sir Ivan Rodgers who would have
been one of the UK government's chief
negotiators with the EU says that he
even he doesn't know what the
negotiating objectives are business
people have a right to be concerned
unless it's been are for the same
reasons that have had us given I think
the same logic applies driving Rogers
he shouldn't be unreasonable either do
you think Ivan Rogers should be replaced
by someone who is Pro brexit
well I think it's the job of a civil
servant to do what the government wants
it to do we've had the referendum the
starting point ought to be we are
leaving the detail precisely what model
will evolve has to be sorted out but the
official has to be totally committed to
to that end and rather looked as though
Sir Ivan possibly wasn't committed to
that end I rather regret that he has
spoken out slightly in the way he did I
don't think that is quite in the ethos
of the civil service and I don't think
it ought to be his job in a resignation
statement to try to undermine the
government that's not what civil
servants should do but there is a bit of
a trend emerging here isn't there of
people who don't seem to agree with
number 10
some might call them experts who've
who've fallen foul of her number 10 in
some way the likes of Lord Lord O'Neill
Mark Carney now Sir Ivan Rodgers these
people are all giving up their jobs or
leaving their posts because they fallen
out with number 10 well I'm not aware
that Mark Carney's leaving his he's
leaving early he's not believing because
of any ray of Briggs
as far as I knew anyway Lord O'Neill
came in to do a specific job he may or
may not have been happy with the way the
present government was continuing to
deal with infrastructure I have no idea
why he he left but this is not part of
any consistent pattern people come and
go the world goes on what would you do
if you're in government now well I think
the objective ought to be to negotiate a
free trade agreement with Europe if we
can't get that the bottom line is I
think we should go back to the WTO and
have an arrangement based on WTO rules
you know the three most important
trading partners of the European Union
don't have any special trade agreement
with the EU six out of the top ten
trading partners have no special
arrangement you know I think businessmen
are too fixated on the
need her some special arrangement it is
possible to trade with Europe without
being a member either of the European
Union or of the single market